i went to ufc 269
and dude it was
my god
i got there
and it was i mean it was so i went with
david spade you know him
and he's faint you know he's pretty
fancy you know he's
uh
tommy boy joe dirt
you know that you know he's that rascal
you know he's that rascal man
you cut on a damn rascal fountain and
he'll fly you know
he's the first
he's the first flow out that [ __ ]
and um
and man we were geeked up we went we
made some bets at the betting window
at the wynn
uh
motel we were staying at the wind motel
and
we made some bets over there at the
bedding window which was pretty cool
kind of old-fashioned
there's not a lot of part there's not a
lot of different par layout you just
walk up and you say okay i want this guy
or this horse
or
you know or this um
[Music]
woman you know there's just a couple
options
so we did that we put we laid some bets
down and then we went over to the fight
so why we get there
dude we're sitting right
behind dana white like i mean
like if he got covered we got covered
you know if he still even had even a vid
or a co or a ov we got you know we were
right there we was breathing the same
we was just volleyballing air
and uh
and that was amazing and then david
sitting next to me then next to him
halle berry
from damn movies from them you know
uh
wherever she's from you know i don't
even know
gorgeous town
you know uh finest fuckington i don't
know where she's from
but she just looked damn vibrant
she looked like a shooting star it just
landed right in her damn heart
and it was just coming out of her eyes
when she talked to you
and i mean it just damn i mean
every time you know when you're just uh
and she loved fighting so she was we're
sitting there just chatting about the
fights
and um
yeah that wasn't that was
you know that was really interesting
um
[Music]
then who else oh tommy lee the draw the
famous musician
was uh there
jared leto was there beautiful guy
dear god
i mean you look at the guy and you're
like damn
you like damn i don't know if this dude
is f i mean is this dude fine as [ __ ]
like you're just
you're liking you're not you're a
straight man you're like this is this
dude fine as [ __ ]
this dude's hotter than uh probably some
of the girlfriends i've ever had
certainly mormon and my my first
girlfriend were really
really strong girl
probably six
six
six foot at the time and we were small
and i remember she would
and i've told this story before she
would uh
pick me up at the bus stop and she'd put
me around her waist and kiss me like
that
just just straight on kiss me like a
damn
god just like and she i think she shaved
dude
i think she shaved a little bit around
her mouth and
she would just
because i remember in the winter when
she would kiss me would burn my face a
little
i just remember my face just feeling
like damn like i just done a damn
business meeting or something
and it was just a lot you know and she
played
i think she played softball i don't know
if we had a softball team she played
somewhere
but she said she did anyway she she wore
the uniform and
she was always punching the mitt and
damn i don't know but
she definitely
she really uh
she really had her way with me that
beautiful girl
what else
uh but yeah the fights were amazing dude
i got to see dominic cruz
so dominic cruz is a fighter he's an
american fighter
um and he looked like tom cruise he's
wearing
he uh
he had already had his fight and we got
there after that
so i knew he'd won because
i've been following him online but i
didn't get to be there and see it
uh
but he's dressed down now he's in street
clothes and so
you know he's just being re you know he
has sunglasses on he comes up and
we're talking
and i'm thinking like i don't and then i
realized oh my god this is freaking
dominick cruz
uh so that was crazy justin gates he was
there he literally just had just
backstage just like who gonna fight who
gonna fight who can i fight who can i
fight
so that was really magnificent
uh
thug rose
i mean it was just crazy just getting to
see all the fighters john anik was there
um dc
you know just getting to be in that
world for a little while
um al jamaine sterling's
uh
this is every i mean and plus all the
fighters that were doing the fighting
so it was just man
i felt like i was in a damn
i was just every i just felt so so much
possibility like i was in a damn
fallopian tube
you know just damn manny this the world
just
god i just felt like anything was
possible
um
yeah so that was great obviously i was
really you know just i was bummed out
not disappointed
that dustin didn't get the victory but
uh
but he's a champ you know he's a champ
and um and he knows it and it is what it
is and
there'll be many more battles and
uh
yeah and so that was my
i'm trying to think of anything else
that happened
while i was there oh
oh they had one point where they got
spayed on the um tv where they like said
you know said he's there and i was
sitting right next to him and
some
a woman
came over with her kid to get a photo
and she's like will you get a photo with
my son
and
i got up to get the photo right when
they were like in a video spade sitting
there so
i kind of missed some of my audio visual
time on the
um
show but
uh
but whatever man it was just dude it was
and then you look and there's just so
many fans and people are just amped up
people are beating each other in the
crowd just [ __ ]
there's somebody somebody brought a
scale and people were they were weighing
each other in the crowd like you weigh
130 you weigh 130 and people just
fighting women against men senior
citizens
against damn [ __ ] uh just cement
toddlers just everybody just
just
[ __ ] annihilating each other
and um and that was it man
that was it
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one